[Music]
so you want to kill deathclaws by the
Dozen build that sick power armor suit
weld it you my friend are gonna need a
safe place to do all that crafting of
weapons armor and the big metal man the
best way to do that without having your
butt chewed off by a radroach is to
build a settlement or two or three he'll
go wild
disclaimer settlements not actually
required when it comes to rebuilding
civilization after a Bostonian
apocalypse worse than Bill Buckner's
blunder back in 86 IO the good news is
you can get to it right away after
exiting vault 111 go right to your old
neighborhood open up your workshop menu
and scrap everything all of it anything
not nailed down anything nailed down it
makes no difference
totally dilapidated houses can be broken
down in one button press voila now get
to building start off with some walls a
shack a few defensive turrets don't
sweat the defense is too much since
after a few days of play in my base
still hasn't seen any shots fired in
anger now if you want to be a better
builder and fallout 4 you should pay
attention to where your skill points are
going specifically to get the most out
of settlements local leader under
charisma will let you build workstations
stores and set up trade routes trade
routes allow you to share resources
across settlements and stores can
generate cash based on population to get
the most out of crafting get some stars
into gun nut to make sure some crazy
weapons are available to you and don't
neglect scrapper which will give you
uncommon components you'll need in
spades
at this stage let's take a quick detour
and talk about resources because it's
not such a clear thing at first most of
the stuff you need for building and
crafting comes from that junk section in
your pip-boy yes keep picking up all
that crap in the environment especially
anything adhesive like duct tape every
time you return to base go to a crafting
station and press transfer all storing
junk in your base makes its resource
components available for crafting but
only that specific base until you set up
trade routes as mentioned earlier after
the early quest when freedom calls
you'll have a base population they will
need food and beds and some happiness
food is planted in fallout 4 and there
are two great sources for your initial
crop the first one is drumlin diner
where you can get some starting seeds
the second is at 10 Pines Bluff where a
small garden is yours for the Topher
head back home and plant away now plop
down a power generator and a recruitment
radio beacon and watch her population
explode if you fancy yourself a budding
IKEA designer later in the game when you
get to Diamond City go find this man
painting the Big Green Monster he'll
send you to clear a local hardware store
and upstairs you'll find a magazine that
lets you expand your domestic home
building agenda and that's about it
bill walls get people keep them happy
set up trade routes and craft craft
craft owing to answer the question you
all have of how high you can build up to
four storeys have fun out there in the
wasteland survivor and for more coverage
of fallout 4 stay tuned to game spot
calm
you